une vraie bête de concours la perfection
des pâtes à la tête
le concours général récompense ses
qualités exceptionnelles
notre star régionale s'était fait tard
deux tonnes élu plus beau taureau 2014
et 2015
malheureusement fêtards le solognot est
mort alors qui pour le remplacer
cette espèce participent au concours
général agricole
il y a les bovins bien sûr les caprins
les ovins les écarts des zinzins et les
porcins les caennais eux peut-être à ce
chien c'est mieux remporter un prix
c'est aussi un moyen de faire de la
publicité pour l'éleveur et de retrouver
des races anciennes et rares eux pas si
bizarre
l'occasion aussi de voir de belles bêtes